so brent that's was my question was
around uh there's a couple of things
that are going to happen over the next
five days and you mentioned that bitcoin
must survive over the next five days uh
and i think that you're talking less
about bitcoin going to zero as much as
just kind of chopping sideways here uh
we have the end of the uh first half of
the year the end of the second quarter
there's all sorts of redemptions and
things that go on with funds and and uh
maybe some force selling there you have
the liquidation risk uh throughout the
industry we've seen a big washout of a
lot of liquidation but doesn't mean it's
over uh you've got the um grayscale
bitcoin trust decision coming up from
the sec in july there could be some
movement around that but there's also
kind of a positive story around the
retail inflows because people get paid
either at the end or beginning of a
month there's also people putting new
capital into whether it's hedge funds or
other types of funds that will go buy
these assets uh and then i think the one
piece we've seen arthur hayes write a
whole piece uh calling out uh the july
fourth holiday having this kind of
illiquidity uh where people can't take
fiat from their bank account and put it
into their crypto account to go and
purchase assets uh if they do drop we
saw when bitcoin went down to seventeen
thousand five hundred dollars uh two or
three weeks ago it was over a three day
weekend there was a banking holiday that
weekend how do you kind of put together
this confluence of events that's about
to occur uh between end of q2 beginning
of a new month you've got the banking
holiday like just talk through how you
uh kind of evaluate what you expect to
happen over the next five days sure i
mean i think you've covered it pretty
much perfectly there so essentially what
you're describing is downside risk until
fourth or fifth of july and then
probably it's safer to be bullish so
when i was saying if you survive i was
talking about trading from the long side
you know people that use that are using
stop losses um certainly bitcoin will
survive the next seven days um god
willing um so i would so the way that i
handle this is to scale in so
i don't think you want to try to like
pin the tail on the donkey and pick like
the perfect entry point so i just want
to separate two things so i'm up till
this point i've mostly been talking
about um structural more like investor
mentality um now i'm talking more trader
mentality which is actually more what i
do um is much more
you know like in for three weeks or
three months kind of stuff that's
generally what i do both in crypto and
in um fiat
or tradify
so the way that i would handle it is
that you think there's going to be
downside pressure
or risk of downside pressure over the
next say say ten seven days so you split
up your purchases over seven days
and then once you're in you pick a stop
loss probably like my stop-loss would be
below the lows at like 69 or something
like that
and then you try to ride the rebound
which i do think july actually i'm
pretty optimistic like i said for the
month of july once we get through this
window
now the one thing
like if you want to play the second
derivative game or like the the
third derivative game if arthur hayes is
talking about it and i'm talking about
it obviously other people are talking
about it too
and that's also part of why i want to
scale in and not just wait for the end
um like you might think that the optimal
strategy would just be like by at 4 pm
on july 4th once all this you know once
the hurricane has passed but the problem
is everyone knows about this so
the risk is actually that that it's
wrong that that analysis is wrong and
you missed the whole thing and we're at
23 8 on july 5th and you're like oh
shoot i missed it so in order to avoid
missing it that's what i'm doing is just
going like you know split it into five
purchases of percent each and then once
i have my average i'll put my stop below
the lows